أجنبي
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] [موسيقى
]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك على
الجيتار الخاص بي ، نعم إنه أمر
مهم جدًا لذلك نحن نعلم
أنه منذ الأيام الأولى لدينا
دعم إجمالي يبلغ حوالي 38 مليارًا
والدعم الكبير الكبير جدًا  من المهم أن تكون أفضل
الأموال التي أنفقناها على الإطلاق ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لأنك تعلم
أننا في الرابعة ، فلنرى أن هذا هو اليوم 457
من الحرب التي كان من المفترض أن تستمر ثلاثة
أيام ،
أنت تدهشني إن بلدك يدهشني إنه
يتعلق بكل شعبنا  ومن بين جميع
أفراد شعبك ، فإن شعبك لديه كل
موظفينا ، يا له من تقدير ، أعني فقط
أنك تذكرني بأنفسنا الأفضل
في أمريكا
أنه كان هناك وقت في أمريكا كنا
نقاتل فيه بهذه الطريقة حتى آخر شخص نذهب
إليه  كن حرا أو مت حرا
أو مت الآن أنت حر نعم
وسنكون والروس يموتون
نعم لكنهم أتوا إلى أراضينا نعم
نحن لا نقاتل هناك
أجنبي